We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. here's
a funny idea that someone has a, which there's
actually more to it.
Let me explain after we listen.
Hey David, I was just wondering if you ever
thought about acting.
I can't be the only viewer who would be interested
in a sit-com starring you and Jimmy from Philly.
Alright, thanks.
Have a great day.
Yeah, so listen, we actually got, after the
last phone call I took from Jimmy from Philly,
which is up on YouTube, it was put up there
over the weekend.
If you've missed it, Jimmy from Philly is
this very angry Trumpist who calls in and
we actually do sort of get along after my
last phone call with them.
A lot of people wrote in and said, David,
wouldn't it be hilarious if Jimmy called in
and like presented a news story?
If you said, Jimmy, I want you to present
to my audience some legislative thing that
happened, some news story, whatever.
It would be absolutely hilarious just to see
what he would do with it.
And this is yet another idea, a sitcom with
Jimmy from Philly and me.
Uh, I love it.
I know a lot of people don't like Jimmy from
Philly every time Jimmy from Philly is on.
I also get a lot of emails that say, David,
stop giving this guy air time.
If there's one thing that I can say about
Jimmy from Philly, other than I don't have
a problem getting along with him in conversation,
he is an absolutely furious Trumpist who hates
everything that is democratic, left, whatever,
liberal, whatever term progressive you want
to apply.
But he's a paid member to the David Pakman
show, which is a, I don't know what to make
of it.
He's a paid member and he has been for months
and he continues to support the show.
So in any case, I don't anticipate any sitcoms
with Jimmy from Philly, but a, just a little
background on some of the reactions to him.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you today.
Two ways to get access to the bonus show,
become a member or become a patron, David
[inaudible],
pacman.com/membership or patrion.com/david
Pakman show.
I will see you then or otherwise on tomorrow's
show, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].